[Music]
well nevada monkey pox cases are now in
the triple digits as the country runs
low on the vaccine there is another way
to control the spread while other
solutions are being considered candace
charles explains how dose sparing is
working for those at risk
i don't want to go through that
reactions to monkey pox raising concerns
as nevada reaches a hundred cases once
it gets into a specific community
then you know
it we expect that it's it's going to
spread from one person to another
southern nevada health district chief
medical officer dr courtney loff tells
me it's one of the reasons they're being
proactive now with three locations to
administer the vaccine wednesday was the
first day the center las vegas offered
the vaccine we are
at the forefront of this disease the
center serves the lgbtq plus community
who are considered high risk the
majority of people that have contracted
the disease are gay bisexual and men who
have sex with men however we do want to
let people know that this disease can
affect anyone searcher director mona
lisa paulo tells me it currently has
more than 1200 doses we
had about a hundred people line up this
morning the food and drug administration
announced it would start dose sparing
which allows one vaccine dose to be
split into five nurse brook tom says it
helps so when we got our original
allotment we had 250 doses
with the dose bearing which is the new
recommendation
it's now a subdermal injection
twice over a 28-day period
so our original 250 doses has turned
into 1250 doses there has been
controversy about those sparing but for
those waiting to get vaccinated the
response was the more the merrier
anything that gets more doses and more
people and more arms that's great i
definitely think everyone is like their
opinions are valid for me i am happy to
get the vaccination kansas charles 8
news now